[Musique]
de la main
Yo
la situation ici en Bolivie est vraie
Il est très important de savoir quel est le
travail des enfants effectué par un de chaque
quatre enfants de moins de 15 ans sont
fonctionnement
[Musique]
comme
c'est-à-dire travailler pendant des millions d'années
ici, la famille signifie obtenir des ressources pour
ça donne l'impression de travailler
pour le bagel food surtout pas
parce qu'à la maison je ne trouvais pas pourquoi
nous en avions marre
[Musique]
concernant le manque d'outils
cool link drive et/ou soutenez-moi et
très graphique sauf démarreur à eau
ville
[Musique]
et
Washington
personne du centre yang ving qui
ils vont probablement au jazz
[Musique]